thank you for hanging in with us today
my name is Naja coming from the st.
Louis chest up in scholastic centers
joining me this evening is mr. Ben
Feingold he's going to give this a recap
on his game with naazy and round six
did you guys believe this fake smile I
did a good job okay okay so well before
this game I wanted this to be my
retirement tournament and this this
really sealed the deal so hopefully I
don't play after this to be a popular
demand now in this position so far I've
played well so the arbiter stopped the
game and wonder if I was using a
computer to cheat because he'd never
seen me play well that he's known me for
years okay and in this position White's
up to pawns for basically no
compensation the normal move is Rick d7
and the computer move his queen c4 which
allows this exchange sacrifice but my
King runs away
okay I'm gonna be rugby 7 just an easy
way instead I thought quite a long time
and I decided I wanted my work on the
e-file instead of on the seventh rank so
I started with the move Rick d4 with the
idea of Queen c4 Jack Ruby g3 and double
on the e-file and of course nasi
immediately took advantage of this
blunder can you at home see that winning
move for black no I know you can't but
maybe you already saw it again so you
have a chance now you just see the game
you still don't remember okay that's the
people I know good job so she
immediately played rook takes check and
the obvious idea is if I take with a
pawn there's this form of my rook and
King I've seen that and I assumed I
could play Queen tags
however after Queen takes and a queen
schrade Bishop c5 wins they're up to two
opinion so route d4 wasn't my best move
of the tournament no okay and zu /
brilliant memory and quick reflexes we
got to this position
yeah black is still winning she's won
upon on a - I played before and somehow
I have waited getting made it no I'm
playing for perpetual check Queen f7
wins but and said there were some King
moves that was fun for everybody
okay and now well during the game we
thought maybe this was a wonderful time
but it turns out it's fine
now this is a very interesting and game
when he takes the xg4 okay and this is
the start of a very interesting endgame
if the black king was on f7 which it
could have been if she'd interposed with
the Queen on f7 black wins very easily
because of King e6 f5 check is
unstoppable f4 is unstoppable
the bishop defends the pawn the bishop
stuffs this point from Queenie and this
King wraps up the H pawn for example and
my King has to stay here for this my
pawn can't go anywhere and my King can't
defend my pawn event Shelby and zoogs
won one possible variation the
spectators and the point after King H
for us now she plays f3 and after here
not King takes pawn because there's a
stalemate right Queen this should take
stalemate but just any legal and black
as widens Upsilon the King has to move
up here in the pawn Queens so with the
with the King on f7 this was an easy one
however that variation I just showed you
cannot happen
luckily and the reason is the king is on
g7 so black can't play King e6 and if
black takes and plays king g6 with the
same idea I have h5 check first and now
this is a draw because I could advance
my pond and after Bishop takes pawn I
can take this point here in fact this is
more accurate so push the pawn first and
then play King f5 okay so black is still
winning it turns out which we realized
after we looked at our engines King f7
g5 now as all of you know at home and
especially here at the club will you do
it's about it is this position is a
known draw the pawn is the wrong color
of the bishop something like Ryan chest
you would know that okay so the threat
is to take the pawn black must play h5
now White has to pass pawns
white and black has one past pond and
this point is blockaded if somehow I can
win this there's no win here for black
okay as a game continued
I'm sure the spawns on b4 makes more
sense and this was very interesting okay
and here King GeForce an easier one but
this move wins fact she was winning
right until the end this was very
interesting indeed and we both had very
little time of this position maybe 30
seconds you're here yeah I almost lost
on time a couple of times okay now if I
take the bishop black Queens so I went
here and now I thought what she did gave
the game away but actually it's a nice
way to win
she played Bishop f2 I came here
Bishop takes pawn g6 and I thought this
was a draw because of the variation King
g6
gave me three f2 King here and when my
opponent sacrifice my palm with her
Bishop when I Queen it I take this pawn
and black has the wrong color grip one
as discussed earlier however black is
winning by one tempo because black
doesn't try to protect the pawn with
their King which he had which he can
push her pawn to h3 Queen takes takes
and now black has one move that wins and
you find it
Bishop h2 stopping the King from
approaching and if my King tries to come
here her King is just in time and the
computer announces me this idea of H 5 H
4 H 3 was oblivious to us even though
we've seen it in other games we were
trying to protect with our King so I was
losing right until the end and since we
both had seconds left
in this position after g6 my opponent
played Bishop f6 instead of the winning
king take g6 and now luckily it's a draw
and I play q3 if King G for now maybe
White has winning chances White's
Queenie was Czech no matter what black
does so with seconds on her clock she
acquiesced to the draw and this is the
known book draw that we had said earlier
so a very suspicious game and a very
suspicious video going 10 minutes in
length well I hope you enjoyed that game
I know I didn't did I but I'm sort of a
bitter hunter I don't like to resign
although I really wanted to resign like
the next 15 was then I thought the game
got pretty interesting when we were both
beings so I thought I might lose but I
thought it'd be really interesting